[Music]
know
me why would you bet on Goliath when we
got bet David value giv values contes
this world of entrepreneurs we get no
value to ha run homie look what I become
I'm I'm the
one all right our guest today with all
the mess that's going on specifically
question we asked this morning on the
podcast with Charlie Kirk is how is it
possible that the supposedly the best
intelligence in the world did not know
that Hamas was training for a year
preparing their soldiers who had no clue
who they were going to attack on a city
they build that matched the city like
the one ones in Israel and then all of a
sudden Egypt says there may be an attack
and you don't do anything and you mean
to tell us we have to believe the fact
that you don't know this was happen it's
kind of tough question for some of us
that we're asking so today's guest
perfect timing Mike Baker worked in the
CIA for 17 years as a covert field
operations officer specializing in
counterterrorism Counter Narcotics he's
drinking a drink right now that may
drink background who know counter
Insurgency operations engaged in
organize and supervis operations around
the globe working in Asia Middle East
Africa Europe and the Soviet Union
former Soviet Union elsewhere and he
host the president's Daily Brief a daily
podcast that's available on Spotify
iTunes and the first TV we're going to
put the link below as well Mike it's
good to have you on again it's great to
be here thank you very much yes
hopefully the we were hoping the
occasion will be different but all the
mess that's going on around the world
it's kind of crazy it's wild but uh for
you Mike with with your background
brother with you worked intelligence
you're in it 17 years historically I've
interviewed the former director one of
the former directors of mad and you talk
to them the level of Pride they have at
how great they are yeah how do they not
know the fact that in attack is about to
be made like this and you know 1,500
people die you know deaths later how do
you not know this was happening yeah uh
well first of all they are excellent
right I mean so but the the bottom line
is this was essentially when people say
look this was their 911 what they're
referring to is you know sort of the
shock of the event and the impact on the
nation that but really when I say it was
like there 911 what I mean is it was the
same type of intelligence failure so I
think what they're finding out now and
what they'll find out further hot wash
on this whole thing is that yeah there
were Clues there were there were
indicators there were bits and pieces of
intelligence um there were again the I'm
not sure how to read the Egyptian Intel
Chief's comments um you know I think we
need to hear more from from him uh from
them in terms of specifics about what
they were what they were talking about
that they said they warned some week and
a half before this but the bottom line
is we had a problem with 9/11 as most
people know at this point in time we
were getting small data points we were
getting little bits of intelligence and
yet the problem was our state our local
Federal the Intel Community everybody
was siloed so you weren't compiling all
that data and and making sense of it you
were having a a a credit card purchase
in Saudi and you were having another
event here in the US and we weren't
dialing all that together right and so
the Holy Grail after 9911 became well
how do you do that how do you how do you
take all these disperate pieces of
intelligence that are coming from a
variety of different uh means and
suddenly focus in on a bigger picture
and understand what it all means now we
we thought we were getting there but the
problem is that it's a it's a human
endeavor and so what I would argue is
that uh we're going to find that the Mad
shinb the the IDF uh border security
everybody they were picking up little
pieces right but for the same problem
which is shit's going to happen
occasionally you're never going to get
it down to a zero some game it's a very
unsatisfactory answer I suspect but it's
it's the honest God's truth so they're
going to have to go through sort of the
same heart-wrenching realization at some
point that they they probably could have
uh prevented this m and Mike what about
the 2hour I'm sorry the 3- hour to 6
hour response once it happened like once
it happened it was just an me stand down
like Stand Down Mikey but but what I'm
saying is yeah more more along the lines
of since you know pride and all that
aside just their presence you it just
kept happening kept happening hours they
even kidnapped people and brought them
back to the strip it's like what how did
they how did they drop that ball yeah
well first of all you have to understand
how long this was in in the planning
stages for right and it was in the
planning stages and it was it was a very
U tight operation in the sense of need
to know right so you know not to
disappear down too many rabbit holes on
this one but there's a lot of layers
here the New York Times came out and in
in some sort of bizarre statement uh
said well according to some sources and
and you know not identified um Iranian
officials were surprised by this because
there is this gyration right now you
know oh my God how can we avoid saying
Iran how can we not say that the Iranian
regime is is essentially responsible for
all of this because without them you
know Hamas is irrelevant right they they
wouldn't exist in in in the way they do
so the idea that the Iranian officials
were caught up surpr well no no no
because you know at the end of the day
this was need to know you had some irgc
some revolutionary guard uh Personnel
responsible for liaison with Hamas uh
they probably actually you know pass
that responsibility on to others because
you know again realizing they wanted to
keep this close hold so there were very
few people in on this there were I
suspect there were a very few number of
of officials within or leaders within
the uh the Brigade the armed element of
Hamas who also understood what was going
on and had the big picture so they were
very smart they probably dumbed down
their Communications significantly to
prevent any sort of uh signals
intercepts um
and it again I it's not satisfactory but
having worked in in uh operations for a
long time this this things happen and
you say how do I how did I miss that so
let me ask a question this way so if
you're us and and we also have one of
the best uh intelligence out there CIA I
like to think so do you think we have
agents do we have agents in Israel do we
have agents in you know all over the
Middle East do we have agents that
gather Intel to bring back to us because
this is also problematic for us it's
very it's very problematic for us yeah
uh the answer is yes uh look U Israel
treats uh Intel kind of the way they
treat uh the military operations right
which is the the pride and we're going
to do it ourselves you know what we'll
take care of ourselves but we have a
very tight Intel relationship regardless
um having said that we also depend
heavily on them for their um for their
hum right frankly and uh was that word
uh human intelligence yeah so they're
extremely care I think one of the
surprises for me from the question of
how how did we miss this is not so much
the we missed technical collection right
although that is also concerning but
it's the it's the source reporting right
it's the human um
because you know I would like to have
thought that they had uh a larger um
network of sources within Gaza and that
at some point somebody would have picked
up on this but again what that points to
is just how close held this operation
was and uh the fact that they were able
to maintain that secrecy over the amount
of time it would have taken to plan this
they had to do re uh wcky they had to do
surveillance reconnaissance on on uh uh
their eventual targets right they didn't
just like stream out and happen upon in
kabut or a village or something they so
they knew what they were doing they had
to stock by weapons they had to go
through training right they had to train
the the Personnel that were going to be
involved in this attack um so it was it
was a remarkable uh in a
sense uh ability of Hamas to do this but
then again they've been at it for a long
time I man I I still have a hard time
hearing believing that because for me
you got a blockade in in Gaza air water
I mean in every possible way they got a
blockade so that means you have people
on the inside side that you can see
what's going on from Top you can have
you know drones you can have so many
different ways to see what they're
working on what you know what why are
why are 28 guys here running into the
house and coming out and running into
the house and coming out and running
into the house and coming out what are
they doing there who's in that house I
mean but but Pat you know they've got
maybe 300 miles of of underground
tunnels right so it's it's like
Minnesota during or Minneapolis during
the cold months right you you never have
to go outside you're always walking
through the skywalks the the tunnel
system that they've built over all these
years and and yes you know uh Israel's
got you know uh ground penetrating radar
and they've got surveillance
capabilities and all the rest of it but
um it it it's remarkable they had and
they hadn't been inside Gaza for what
nine years yeah since the disengagement
in' 05 longer than that so you 17 years
uh by the way have you seen the videos
of what those tunnels looks like in
Hamas there's there's plenty of videos
in inside the Hamas tunnels that they
have if you if you WRA if you find one
of the clip like this one here shows you
know inside gaza's uh underground tunnel
there's plenty Wall Street Journal has
it uh what they've built over the years
it it gives it gives inside on what is
that one of
them if you just Ty in inside Gaza
tunnel see if on Twitter anything comes
up that's Gaza tunnel go ahead Adam oh
you're pulling that up Rob uh just to be
clear CIA intelligence you know there's
conversations out
there that somehow they turned a BL
Blind Eye to this the IDF mad Netanyahu
like you know what like almost kind of
like the 911 stories like look you know
they turned a BL ey to it there was fair
warning and you know there whether it's
the big oil or military-industrial
complex they kind you know there was
some we'll look at the other way and
because there's going to be enrichment
on the other side of this from a CIA
perspective what's the likelihood that
Netanyahu mad IDF sort of was like yeah
we'll let them attack we'll let this
kind of slide maybe it got a little more
out of hand than we suspected but now we
sort of have a green light to full
attack what's the likelihood that they
sort of co-signed this yeah I mean I I I
I get you know I'm not a buyer on on
things like that right um it's because
in part because Israel knows exactly
where this is going right it the part of
the depression or the depressing part
about the Middle East is how consistent
it it always plays out out so they know
or they knew no matter how horrific the
hamas's attacks were and the brutality
that was displayed they knew that as
soon as you started getting a body count
in in Gaza that the whole narrative
social media narrative you know the the
mainstream media narrative was going to
start focusing on that right I mean we
the the the lack of of of interest in
from a a segment of society who just
willing to set aside the the brutal of
those attacks and say well geez look at
the you know look at the rising
casualties in Gaza you know and and as
if they're trying to you know create
some sort of equivalence here yeah um
and and then and and then also the
bottom line is Hamas doesn't give a
about dead Palestinians they don't I
mean that's that's the point of what
they do what does that mean exactly
because there's sort of this
equivocation of like you know Gaza is
Hamas and Gaza is a Palestinian and
Palestine and they're living in this
open air prison and then Hamas is just
you know they're fight they're freedom
fighters from a CIA perspective Hamas is
Hezbollah their Isis are they fullon
what they are perceived to be which is a
Islamic terrorist group well they're
they're uh useful very useful proxies
that they're basically what Iran is done
is is surround you know to a significant
degree Israel with a couple of terrorist
armies right and but what I mean by
Hamas not caring about casualties that's
their currency that's their leverage
right they've got Hamas has an extremely
sophisticated public relations element
right most of them sitting comfortably
over and gutter so but they know and and
and part of it is their their
willingness over the years to do exactly
what they know is always going to result
in dead casual or dead civilians
embeding themselves you know putting
their stockpiles uh adjacent to or
within civilian infrastructure um their
their military command centers you know
their their personnel they they know
what they're doing right and so they
understand that as soon as you start
getting civilian casualties the world is
going to turn right and it's going to
it's going to force an issue and sure
enough now there is as much or probably
more talk um about that than about the
you know the the reason why this is
happening you know so I would argue
civilians I mean Palestinian
civilians if they die they're victims of
Hamas as well right yeah it was an
expion it was a rocket that came in from
Israel but the reason you're having this
is is because of of Hamas why did they I
that's just no why why do they vote for
Hamas meaning they have I don't know
their election system in in Gaza or the
West Bank in Palestine but it used to be
the PLO under yasu Arafat and then uh
Palestinian Liberation uh organization
but they voted for Hamas in ' 07 MH and
they still run Gaza I don't know how
these elction work but why do they vote
for Hamas versus another option was it
fata or other options that that maybe
would serve the people better than a
militant terrorist group I again that's
way outside my pay grade I have no idea
but I would argue that there are a lot
of of of citizens or residents of Gaza
who aren't Affiliated or associated with
uh Hamas right I mean look it's shitty
living right it's it's awful 50%
unemployment I mean it's just it's
horrible it's only going to get worse
you point it's going to get worse no
question about it by the way I got a we
have a friend right now in Israel uh
who's there as we speak uh Jason Lions
Jewish Republican liaison former
chairman of the United States Israel
security Alliance and has a degree
diploma from Harvard Business School and
negotiation master Jason can you hear
us Patrick how are you thank you I hope
you can see me and hear me with the old
city in Jerusalem in the background I
can I can so how are things there if you
were to give us a understanding or what
the feelings like when you're talking to
people how are things right now in
Jerusalem I would say I would equate it
as Floridians is the come before the
storm we know a cur a hurricane five is
coming uh the most beautiful weather is
usually a few hours before the hurricane
hits I would assume that within the next
coming days the worlds will see an
incursion like nothing they've seen
before
there is no one in the world that has
actually ever seen the MIT of the
Israeli
Army uh they've been very
meticulous Precision like in dealing
with terrorists specifically
Hamas over the last 30
years and they have done everything they
could possibly do to avoid collateral
damage uh sadly there will be collateral
damage
the biggest challenge we have right now
is there's approximately 150 hostages
many Nationals from foreign countries we
have a number of diplomats here I am
meeting later on this evening very lates
possibly early this morning with
representative
Mills who uh set this up came out here
to try to do some negotiations I don't
want to go into all the details the
Secretary of state is right next door to
me uh I'm at the King David Hotel he's
literally next
door uh and uh I want to first of all
thank Senator Rick
Scott uh who has uh been in touch with
me hourly over the last week since the
war broke out what else can I answer for
you Patrick you know you hear messages
about the the left and the right in
Israel the left is like hey why don't we
uh negotiate and you know let's let's
figure out a way to make this work and
you know these guys are saying every
time you bomb us you know we're going to
be you know showcasing and taking out
one of the hostages and the right is
saying no we cannot negotiate with
terrorists that's what the media saying
are you feeling a more of a unified
group going up against Hamas or is there
some sort some level of a division
between the people in
Israel well I think you know in the past
the Israelis have Tri red a thousand for
one uh you know in baseball that's
probably the equivalent of a player to
be named later uh the horrible trade uh
they did it for shalet many years
ago um you know now you have probably a
tremendous amount of pressure coming
from the Americans the Germans
Australians they all have hostages there
you know they they they don't want to be
part of this so nanahu is walking a very
fine line right now and uh President
Biden who I thought spoke quite well the
other day you know let's see where the
action is but I I know I don't like to
unnecessarily throw people under the bus
even though his relationship with Israel
to date hasn't been great but he did
give a very strong speech the other day
and uh I think for the most part
Israelis have had
enough uh I was at the base probably
closest to Gaza two days ago I was with
the major general he pulled me aside
because he didn't want his soldiers
hearing what he was telling me but he
tried to describe to
me the catastrophic things that he
personally
witnessed over the last 48 hours seeing
not just children
babies
heads uh
decapitated little girls with blood all
over them women that had been raped and
left for dead these are things that you
only see in the
movies and they get a very lousy rating
like uh a rated R rating because of the
violence I mean we have never seen other
than maybe some of the things that Isis
have done the barbaric actions of uh
animals I can't even call them human
beings I mean who burns babies
to try to make a point and I think one
of your guests on the show as I was
logging on mentioned about the vote
there's no vote Hamas hands you a ballot
and there's a machine gun pointed to
your head uh this is who you need to
vote for so it's a complete sham of a
vote uh these are the worst people in
the worlds and they need to be
completely
eradicated uh because of the hostages
it's complic ated right now and I think
the reason why the Israelis haven't gone
in yet is because they're trying to do
everything they can to secure the
release of these hostages and the United
States who's now sent a second aircraft
carrier is making sure that the
Americans uh get out as well so that's
the situation right now the left and the
right uh there's nothing that unifies
this country more than a common enemy
and that's what you have right now and
Hamas is terrible as the things they've
done over the last four days uh they
were able to do something that no
politician has been able to do over the
last 70 years in this country unite them
so uh kudos to Hamas for waking up the
sleeping
Giants Jason uh this is Adam thank you
for your perspective um you talk about
the Calm before the storm uh where the
IDF is getting ready to attack I presume
and Go full force you talked about the
barbaric nature and the barbarism of
Hamas um what can the people that are
not familiar with how IDF operates learn
meaning allegedly they sent 3,000 texts
to um Palestinian citizens urging them
to leave they've dropped leaflets
they've dropped food before they do
what's called I believe roof knocks
that's saying hey you've got five
minutes to vacate the building cuz we've
identified this building as a place that
a missile came from so meaning they're
trying to limit civilian casualties uh
whereas obviously Hamas is will will
gladly rape and pillage whoever they
come across what should the world know
about how the IDF is operating to save
civilan
lives well you know I think you're going
to see a new playbook and I think a lot
of Palestinians are going to get killed
there's nowhere to
go um it's a
little unfair
uh you have an ocean on one side a sea
you have Egypt which was letting in at
the most 2000 a day uh and then of
course to the north you have the
Israelis uh there's nowhere for the
Palestinians to go this is a horrible
situation uh one of your guests
eloquently put this that Hamas put the
Palestinians in this pigeon hole right
now this is a terrible situation but
they cross the line and as I mentioned
before
Precision into all of the killings of
Kamas leadership over the last 20 years
and I'm afraid that Precision is going
to WAN over the next couple of days and
the collateral damage will be heavy and
another one of your uh podcast members I
think also
mentioned something to the effect that
uh you know what can they do about it
well I think the
Israelis value life as much as any
nation in the world and I still believe
even though there will be some
collateral damage the Israelis will do
everything possible to minimize the
collateral damage quick followup you you
sort you sort of said that that you
might want to start buckle up race for
impact cuz civilian casualties uh might
be possible maybe even unavoidable um
you know there's winning the actual War
then there's winning the pr War um yeah
Mike Baker mentioned how good the Hamas
is at PR and and uh putting spreading
their their uh basically
lies from a PR perspective why would
Israel want to kill civilian lives even
if it's
unavoidable they don't want to the
problem is they're all entangled with
each other I mean up until four days ago
they were using the Palestinians as
human Shields that means that they're
shooting thousands of missiles and the
Israelis know where the missiles are
coming from so the reason why the
Israelis don't take out those
installation systems because they're
surrounded by
Palestinians now they up the game they
took 150 Israelis slash semi- israelies
and they've put them in those places so
now you got to think twice before take
out these
rockets and that's the quandry that
they're in right now Mike Vinnie any
questions you guys good yeah what have
you heard uh it's it's Mike Baker Jason
what what have you heard about Egypt's
willingness perhaps to allow Palestinian
refugees to cross into uh Egypt the
numbers were
low uh that I heard uh it's possible
that CC will get enormous pressure from
the United
States uh he might get a boatload of
Buddy for accepting them that's
something that's you know there's back
channelings right now that are going on
with the Egyptians for that very reason
there's a lot of back channeling going
on with the qataris right now you know
they spent $200 billion dollar on the
World Cup and that money could go up for
smoke real fast if uh they don't play
ball with the United States uh the
United States has a relationship with
qar uh but it's uh one of these Mutual
beneficial relationships we have a base
there and we tend to look the other way
it's hard to look the other way when the
leader of Kamas is living in a palace
and has refuge in that country and I
have a very good
relationship with the royal family over
there and uh they're not happy about the
situation either uh but things are let's
say in the works of trying to do
something to uh alleviate their
pressures uh and Jason this is Vincent
uh God bless you and I hope everything
is uh you stay safe and everything goes
good over there while you're there um a
couple days ago the exhe head of uh
Hamas khed mashal called for tomorrow
for Friday the 13th to be an
international basically a day of
terrorism how how much do you think that
we should heed to his warning and what
is the security apparatus on high alert
where you are because you know obviously
it you know it was caught you know with
its pants down necessarily but how how
do you think how serious is this warning
from from Khaled
mhal you know I think anybody that kills
babies and throws them in fires I would
take their threats fairly seriously
whether or not the Israeli Arabs you
know I am in a hotel right now which has
hosted probably every president since
Linden
Johnson um and there are probably 30 or
40 Arab Israelis that are working here
and don't think for a moment that the
guests here at this hotel weren't
thinking what are the possibilities that
these guys will take a kitchen knife you
know and run through the dining room uh
we just heard that in the old city which
is right behind
me uh two people were shot today so yes
there is a risk um I would say Jerusalem
is probably the least risky uh we did go
to a number of places in Israel today
that I would say is a little bit more
concerning uh the answer is I don't want
to DARE the terrorists by telling that
I'm not concerned about it so I'm going
to say that I'm hopeful that tomorrow
will be peaceful uh I plan on staying
here in Jerusalem uh we do have added
security here I have a personal detail
myself um you know I have kids I have a
wife I have parents they're
concerned uh I will tell you that is a
uh Jewish American when I was a young
boy my mother used to tell me that every
Jew needs a passport in case one day
they have to run to Israel this is the
first time in my 55 years where I have
actually seen people trying to get
passports to run away from Israel it's a
very sad day for the Jewish people a lot
of us have family members that were in
the Holocaust my mother-in-law was born
in a DP Camp my wife lost Grand parents
from both sides and five children and
had to start over again and my wife's
Grandmother Had has numbers on her arm
she was in owitz so you know this is a
very scary time and somebody mentions
about proxies whether it was Iran with
Hezbollah and so on and so forth uh Iran
is a wonderful country the people of
Iran are as good as they come I know
Patrick is from there and uh if Patrick
was an American citizen I think he could
be president the United States one day
we've spoken about that and I think
these are bad app
regimes these are not bad people there's
the Palestinian people for the most part
are good people I get a little slack
sometimes when I say that to my Jewish
friends but the fact is is that they're
pigeon hold right now they don't want to
be there anymore than anybody else so
let's hope for the best I hope the world
understands one of your guests was made
a brilliant observation that in a couple
days you're going to see headlines like
25,000 Palestinians died and 2,000
Israelis died and people are going to
start doing the math and say well that
doesn't sound right but unfortunately in
about a week or two I'm predicting that
the world will forget how this started
and it will go back to the basics of it
was the Israelis AP paride state so on
and so forth and I hope at least this
time with these children children that
were slaughtered these women that were
raped these daughters and
sons I was telling Patrick before that I
had just left the house of two parents
who lost their son last night uh you
know they said goodbye to him last night
and and that's it and the funeral was
probably going to be a few hours later
but I hope the world uh remembers how
this began because it is going to end
uh with the full might of the
IDF and in a couple of weeks people are
going to forget and they're going to say
oh the IDF just railroaded these people
and hos them down but try to remember if
you
can how this all started Jason this is
Adam again one more question for you um
Jewish American as well um I love
America um I I I love Israel as well I
was just there 3 months ago I took my
mother for the first time in 30 years
she used to live on a kibutz she did not
recognize the country CU she's like oh
my God it's like the economic growth is
has been incredible um my question is
about uh BB Netanyahu when I was there I
saw the protest everything that's going
on in the knesset the parliament the
Supreme Court you know uh Tel Aviv super
liberal it was right after their pride
week obviously Jerusalem traditional
conservative the political upheaval is
is is tangible there you could feel it
so what's the future of BB is is he um
what do the people feel about him uh
there you know there's conversations
that he's sort of turned a blind eye to
kind of allow this to happen so he can
sort of gain more power and have more
excuses to do anything like this from
your perspective that he's the longest
running prime minister in Israeli
history I think this is like his fifth
term in 16 years what's the future of
BB I would never bet bib nanyu out you
know let's go through his
history his uh brother was a decorated
soldier he lost his life at
inbi it was a mission that he
ran uh he was the only person that was
killed in that mission it was one of the
most heroic events ever in the history
of this
country um you know whether or not he
got a had start because of the name
recognition uh he's a brilliant person
BBE uh MIT he was United Nations
Ambassador uh he won an election against
Perez um and you know I offered him a
job once as a uh a head hunter many
years ago he was out of work for a while
we met in the uh David
Citadel and I remember he told me me
that uh the winds can change very
quickly in Israel and that's been his
career his career is had some ups and
downs but uh you're 100% correct he's
the longest standing prime minister he
just passed his 16th
year uh which is I believe three more
years than any other prime minister
since
1948 and BB is in a quandry right now
you know they're trying to go after him
trying to indict him whether or not you
believe the indictments are real or
bogus he has had no choice because he
himself is Pigeon hold to try to change
this Supreme Court
ruling um so that has caused problems
it's caused a lot of issues with Venture
Capital money that would flow into
Israel as
well uh the Liberals are not too happy
about it and there was a tremendous
amount of division in this country up
until the war started a couple days ago
um my guess is is that you know is he
completely responsible for
one piece of
offense around the entire country that
was breached I mean that's how they got
in um at the end of the day yeah I guess
the buck stops with the CEO the company
but there were probably several people
between uh the foot Soldier and the
commanderin-chief that dropped the ball
on this particular one I think over time
you know there will be
investigations how this happened uh the
Israelis are
embarrassed uh the same way the United
States was embarrassed in September 11th
uh you know how did that happen but we
tend to Rally around our leaders during
wartime and BB is a
Survivor uh he's lost family members in
war and I think he's earned a certain
amount of respect similar to a gold star
family and uh my prediction is is that
he'll be okay in the end and I think the
Israelis will rally around him I'm happy
that they were able to do this Unity
government in the 11th hour and when
Israelis unit they're extremely powerful
so that's what Hamas is going to be up
against the United Israel over the next
couple of months and uh I I think when
this is over you'll have a similar
outcome to Isis where they will totally
wipe out uh you know you'll be able to
Google Hamas and it just won't exist
anymore it'll say something like a
former terrorist
organization and uh the hopeful outcome
that will come out of this Jason uh
appreciate your time be safe and I will
reach out to you after this podcast over
with again thank you for your
time Patrick thank you as well be safe
my friends yes sir Take Care thank you
he's in the thick of it he he's in it
he's in it right now Mike what do you
what did you think about what he
said well first thing is it's and this
is going to sound really cynical um and
we've we've heard this from others
they're going to smash himas they're
going to destroy it they're going to
annihilate it look I spent a lot of time
in counterterrorist operations and
that's not how it works you know it's
not again it's not a zero sum game so
you can degrade and you can mitigate
risk and you can you know remove certain
targets but there's some underlying
issues here that creates this bottomless
well of potential new recruits right and
it's just you know I worry sometimes
when they say okay our you know
Netanyahu said it again today we're
going to crush him we're going to
destroy him we're going to it's
it's you know I don't know call me
cynical it's not possible why not um
look Isis still exists right I mean he
he referenced isic say it's going to be
just like Isis well former you know
whatever yeah it's Isis is still there
right and they're still and they're
they're trying to reconstitute and and
um the the the we can I'm not saying you
can't do significant damage right uh
part of that is is dependent on how
solid your your operational intelligence
is and how quickly you can act on that
intelligence so we can do a great deal
of damage
but um I would argue that if you want to
destroy Hamas you've got to get rid of
the Iran regime that's I mean that's
head of the snake and it's not you know
again he's absolutely right but nobody
nobody's nobody's arguing as Iranian
people just like with G and and the
Communist Regime and his his locked down
on the people nobody's arguing about the
Chinese people it's they're they're
fantastic it's social cultural great
history but it's this regime and the the
Iranian regime as far as you know I'm
not going to shift off this position
they're responsible you know for the
vast you know uh majority of funding for
Hamas over the years it's always coming
from from Iran same with Hezbollah and
they've done it for a reason because
they they've got this ability now to
surround Israel and to look and and also
look they Hamas knows Hezbollah knows if
there's stability right like if you got
this agreement between the Saudis and
Israelis and you got the Gulf States in
there and they suddenly and and and
you've get without instability you know
what is Hamas right what what is
Hezbollah and you know frankly what is
the regime so but I think you can't take
those you you can degrade them
significantly but you're not going to
you're not going
to just not going to remove the core
problem quick followup to that cuz I
fully agree that's where I was going
with this I respect to Jason but the
whole eliminating Hamas uh I think is uh
a pipe dream you know because Hamas
spouted from the Muslim Brotherhood
which came from Islamic uh
fundamentalists and then you know hasb
there's a new group will pop up you're
not going to CH like if you eliminate
Hamas you're not going to eliminate the
ideology or who's funding the ideology
which is which is Iran and look just to
be clear like I have I'm Jewish I have
Arab friends I have Muslim friends I
have Christian friends like we do not
want war with Islam nobody does the West
this is not the Crusades these are
specific SE so if there's what two
billion Muslims in the world 1.8 billion
Muslims 99% let's say let's say they're
good they want no problem this the
problem is let's say the 1% that's 18
million people that are Islamic let's
just say it's 1% by the way that's
that's more than how many Jews exist in
the world 16 million so it it from a
numbers perspective here if you just
take 1% of two billion people you're
talking 18 20 million people that want
death that want destruction you're never
going to fix it by just eliminating let
me read this so Iran's kame hailes Hamas
warns retaliation could be greater
disaster this is Washington examiner
story K praised Hamas for inflicting an
irreparable defeat on Israel but Deni
direct responsibility for the attack
warning that Israel's response could
lead to a greater disaster he stated it
is unlikely that the unur unsur regime
will be able to use the help of the West
to repair the Deep impacts that this
incident has left on its ruling
structures questions regarding Iran's
role in the Hamas attack have risen with
conf iting reports from Hamas reports
Hamas sources and Western observers
emphasizing Iran's General support for
the group Israeli Prime Minister
Netanyahu has declared an un
unprecedented military offensive against
Hamas and Gaza and characterized it as a
clash of civil civilizations he called
for international support stating in
fighting Hamas Israel is not only
fighting for its own people it's
fighting for every country that stands
against barbarism so he's saying this K
is saying that to a you're saying okay
you take out Hamas so what as long as
Iran's there Iran's there so now you got
some people that criticizing because
your position sounds like what Nikki
Haley said what Lindsey Graham said we
got to go after Iran right we got to go
attack Iran is that kind of what you're
saying well yeah I mean Lindsey Graham
came out and said you know we have to
start bombing the oil refineries and and
yeah if you if you engaged in a military
conflict then your logical choices are
oil refineries and and you know start
you know busting the the uh their their
nuke facilities um for their weapons
program but that's not necessarily what
I'm talking about I'm talking about look
we
we had a maximum uh pressure approach
right which it it's it's a little
unsatisfactory and it never really makes
regime change necessarily uh because
they just keep tightening the screws on
the on the general population but I
think you you we've got to do something
other than what has been taking place
over the past couple of years right like
they the Biden Administration was very
vocal about it they come coming in it
was a brand new day with Iran right
we're getting off that maximum pressure
approach they staffed most of their Iran
focused positions right from Robert Mali
to to a variety of other uh desk
positions at the Pentagon and and state
department with people who believe that
same thing right Mali has been very
disdainful of any sort of maximum
pressure approach to Iran and now
mysteriously has had his security
clearances pulled uh is on suspension
and uh you know we're not hearing boo
about it from from the administr
but that and and then there's this idea
look they're still going through these
contortions secretary blinkin said it
again today you know said uh you know I
just have to correct this misperception
somehow that that you know we've we've
given these $6 billion and unfrozen
assets and somehow you know they're
doing everything possible to avoid uh
the obvious which is without Iran's
support training technical assistance uh
Hamas would not have gotten to a
position where they could accomplish
what they did right to over the weekend
and so they you know they're bending
over backwards to avoid and I get it you
you know you're You're Nobody wants as
you pointed out direct military conflict
right with with Iran we we would like to
find other ways to make this happen but
every time an Administration tries to
approach and deal with Iran and and
offer you know they get kicked in the
ass by the Iranian regime so I at some
point what do you do well okay first of
all we take away the6 billion dollars
that's something we could accomplish
here in the next 10 minutes um and then
we actually get serious again about oil
sanctions uh and we put the screws down
on them it's the only time the only time
they ever you know uh Aquas or or or
start to act as if they're going to do
is when you you I hate to say it but
when you've really screwed them down and
otherwise they're just going to engage
in in this and I'm not saying they drew
up the operational plan but I guarantee
you there were there were liaison
Personnel within the irgc that are
assigned to deal with Hamas and
Hezbollah who were very aware of all of
this what do they fear meaning we talk
about Iran as if they're Untouchable
meaning you can't go to war with Iran
it's going to start this oh my God we we
can't and let them enrich the nuclear
weapons because they're going to do this
but we can't pull out of it because it
sounds like there's no options it it
almost sounds like we we we we're in the
nuclear deal we're out of the nuclear
deal John K's going there Trump pulls
out like it sounds like we have no
uniformity whatsoever and they're almost
Untouchable yeah so if you're like from
your perspective or even Pat's
perspective as well what do they fear
the the ayatolla the irgc that you're
talking about what do they fear the most
well I think i' i' let Pat talk about
that but I would I would jump in just
for a second and say I think they fear
the same thing that g fears same thing
that Putin fears they they fear losing
control of the population right and and
I I would argue that there's a sizable
part of the population that is again not
uh inclined towards the Iranian regime
but have few options um but that's what
they fear they fear losing control je
spends you know every day trying to
figure out how do I you know not have
that happen and there's there's you
know not an insignificant uh amount of
protests that take place inside of China
that we never hear about and and and and
that's their number one fear within that
the CCP is is is that I would argue the
same thing with the Irani regime they
just want Power they want control you
know and they Envision themselves they
they they want to be the um undis
indisputed Undisputed I'm talking like
President Bush um they want to be the
Undisputed uh you know Regional leader
um obviously Saudi has other views on
that um but it is it's incredibly
complex I mean that the Iranian you know
president just just had a phone call
with MBS over in Saudi um to talk about
what's going on in Gaza and you think
really because I'm pretty sure one of
your objectives here was to you know
Screw over that potential you know peace
treaty with isace treat with is of
course you're talking about that say
this is from Daily Mail Iran's president
Saudi Crown Prince hold their first ever
phone call Iranian president RI and S uh
Saudi Crown Prince mmed bin Salam Salman
engaged in their inaugural phone
conversation focused on the recent Hamas
attack in Israel RI affirmed the need to
end war crimes against Palestine while a
Saudi Crown Prince declared the kingdom
is making all efforts possible to stop
the ongoing escalation reiterating Saudi
Arabia stance against targeting
civilians in response to Iran's reported
support for Hamas US President Joe Biden
issued a stark warning stating we made
it clear to the Iranians be careful he
disclosed details of a new arm armed
shipment to Israel including
interceptors for the Iron Dome defense
system and ammunition for the Israeli
Defense Force following an attack by
Hamas militants that resulted to an over
1,200 casualties so that that phone call
looks like Saudi is playing kind of like
trying to keep everybody happy with the
deal hey we were about to have a deal
with Israel we were about to make them
official but we still can't you know
lose our relationship with Hamas with
with Palestine and he's trying to you
know kind of play both sides and I don't
know how successful he can be doing that
yeah I agree with you that's that
strikes me as a very dangerous game and
I think NBS is a very Savvy individual
but um you know he's going to at some
point he's going to have to make a
decision here I would argue that look
the Saudi you know legitimately would
like to have normalized relations with
Israel right it's just going forward it
makes good sense as would I would say
also that the Gulf States I would think
would feel the same way but why why why
why would Saudi or the Gulf States want
to have a normalized relationship with
Israel uh you know what I think they
would put U development Economic
Development um stability which also
promotes economic debility ahead of you
know kind of this this constant regional
conflict which goes back to the Bronze
Age
so yeah which again is is probably why
it won't happen because it goes back to
the bronze we're starting to see more
and more and more since NBS and the
Jamal kogi thing horrible horrible oh
God yeah and I mean the 911 whatever the
but it would seem that
MBS um is trying to do a PR campaign
whether it's real or actually you know
uh a facade to sort of uh re Enlighten
the world on what Saudi Arabia is right
so as you see Iran becoming more of a
social International Pariah you're
starting to see Saudi Arabia talk about
these peace treaties talk about arms
deals with the United States you seeing
what they're doing doing in the sports
PR World they started the live golf
thing you're starting to see them buy
sports franchises NBS has basically come
out and said yeah we we are doing that
to ingratiate ourselves into the to the
real world we've seen the economic
success of the UAE saudi's like all
right well we've got oil money too like
why be a pariah when we can be a player
and there's also this they they need to
well we need them to be but they want to
be a counterbalance to Iran right so um
yeah of the day doesn't it behoove them
to
uh treat or enable Iran to be that
social Pari and and prop themselves up
look look we're not that bad yeah good
use of the word behoove by I love love
when use the big words so Mike with all
the stuff that's happening with you know
the the prisoner trade we throw in you
know the Biden Administration throws in
$6 billion doar which is ridiculous how
much do you think of what's Happening
falls on the fact that we do have such a
weak leader like because they know you
know they're not going to really press
them that hard but I mean think about it
they know that we're Israel's number one
Ally but you're still doing some stuff
like that how much does that come into
play when you're making decisions to go
attack and do all this I mean I'm pretty
sure they look at the big picture
they're not they're not just going to
just kill there's something deeper than
that isn't it well yeah I mean I think
there's it doesn't help when as Pat said
you have a sort of this back and forth
in policy and you know and and I I think
there's there's inconsistency and in US
positions and and so and I think also
the this this soft approach on Iran um
you know frankly caused a lot of concern
within the Saudis and also the Gulf
States as to you know okay where is the
US going here you know what are they
doing what's their intention and so I
think I don't know but I as far as
Iran's uh intentions yeah I think they
just it's a destabilization of the
region they don't they don't view a
because I don't think they view
themselves as coming out on top in a
region that is increasingly peaceful and
stable so they would see themselves
being further and further isolated I
suspect the regime again I'm talking
about but it's uh yeah it but I I think
the problem's going to be and and Jason
uh you know talked about it h you saying
you know hopefully in a couple of weeks
or three or four weeks when casualties
that people will remember what happened
I'm not an optimistic person sometimes
and I don't think people are going to
remember how this all kicked off yeah
they're going to move on and by the way
Adam
you your Adam your number was how how
many how many billion uh Muslims on in
the world 1.8 billion 1.8 billion and
you said a 1% of the of the population
are just hate like radicalize some would
say that's a low number I was going to
say Pat the the remember the the bill
Mah podcast 25% is let's say 20 to 25
conserv that's a conservative number
that is hundreds of millions of people
that are just like you're not going to
change their mind it's just hate get rid
of them and like so I was just trying to
make a point that that number that you
you are Beyond conservative by the way
let's let's play uh uh okay let's be
positive no we can fix this okay all
right so if you got hundreds of millions
of people tens of millions of people
with that level of hate or belief like
for example if you read the charter if
you read hamas's Charter 1988 yeah
versus the 2017 Charter the original
charter you know what it says if he can
pull it up Rob I don't know if you have
or not if you don't have it I'll just
read it to you this is when it their
first one p this is their Charter this
is what like their their their Bill of
Rights okay let me read you their Bill
of Rights here's hamas's Bill of Rights
to og1 the 1988 which is what 35 years
ago what they were founded on their
founding original founding principle the
complete destru it's four themes number
one the complete
destruction of Israel as an essential
condition for the liberation of
Palestine and the establishment of a
Theocratic State based on Islamic law
Sharia law number one number two the
need for both unrestrained and unseizing
holy war Jihad to attain the above
objective Point number one number three
the deliberate disdain for and dismissal
of any negotiated resolution or
political settlement of Jewish and
Muslim claims to the Holy Land number
four the reinforcement of historical
anti-semitic tropes and calumnies
married to Sinister conspiracy theories
okay I mean these are True Believers
that believe that now keep this in mind
so that's what they believe in when you
raise your raise your kids if you're a
Bears fan your kids are probably a Bears
fan you're a Lakers fan they're a Lakers
fan you're this most of the time
religion beliefs is going to be the same
right okay MH now this is what's
interesting about this this is why I had
the
conversation is they're having more kids
per woman than any other religion in the
world okay so whatever this number is it
ain't going away it's going to get
bigger and bigger and bigger and bigger
by 2050 you're GNA you think right now
like oh my god look who's the senate or
congress Muslim this D 2050 it's going
to be like oh my God 20 30 40 50
hundreds involved right now in the last
M midterms election 82 or 83 Muslim
elected officials city council not not
necessarily Congress and Senate but just
different positions that they God from a
competitor myself I respect how
competitive they are to win the war of
them being able to get everybody to be
baptized in their way of living okay in
their their way that they view the world
should be right the laws that they
follow these are not people that are
playing around so when you're saying
numbers like that this is not going to
slow down anytime soon so what do you do
okay you kill 20,000 Palestinians and
Hamas all right say you kill 50,000 say
you kill 100,000 and then what do you do
okay they got 2.1 million people living
in Gaza by the way zero zero Israelis
2.1 million Palestinians and to your
point about a million of those are young
kids young kids 50% unemployment you
know I think it's I don't know if it's
NATO or who gives them money you or
somebody gives them money 720 $730
million and they say the money doesn't
end up going to the people they keep it
at the top and they go Bu weapons man so
this is kind of like hey you should kind
of get rid of the blockade because
you're not allowing business to come
through here and Israel says no we're
not removing a blockade matter of fact
we're going to shut it down right now
for water and food but somehow someway
they're getting food and you know
shelter they're getting food and water
to these guys here's the
point number one is this ever going to
stop okay you know preventative so let's
just say preventative right you buy life
insurance not because you're going to
die tomorrow you buy because
what guaranteed you're eventually going
to
die
right you know you you get on auto
insurance not because you're going to
get into an accident tomorrow because
the possibil if it happens you're
protected right what is insurance right
now okay my concern right now is it's
it's easy to want to retaliate trust me
there's different parties involved
Palestinians they're going to give their
argument which is what how come you're
not sharing our side of the story did
you not see the father that's walking
out with the daughter and the k dude we
see all of that and it's heartbreaking
okay then you hear the story of Israeli
who are Israeli Americans who are here
versus Israelis who are in Israel left
and right to one side let's destroy them
all let's get rid of them let's make
this all our land let's make it you can
only be a Israeli to come back to the
Holy Land and this is it right the other
side is like well no let's kind of
figure out a way to negotiate with them
then there's everybody else in the world
that's not directly involved with it
you're not Palestinian you're not a Jew
maybe you're a Christian Living in
America maybe you're a you know Mormon
living in you know whatever Brazil I
don't know what you are you're sitting
there saying look this Brazilian Mormon
Brazilian believe it or not I I met a I
met a I met a Cuban bahai which is kind
of weird bahai Cuban yeah apparently
there's like a bahai church in Cuba out
of all places hilar but the point the
question I'm asking is okay so first
starts there and then all of a sudden
residual effects no no no
boom front door your house your city
your community now what how do you
prevent from that happening right that's
the concern so I don't think any of this
is going to be slowing
down but do I think they're going to
retaliate and they're going to do
something yeah I think so how bad is it
going to be I don't know 20,000 50,000
100,000 I don't know whatever that
number is you're going to get retali
iation from the other side you you'll
definitely get retaliation I think where
it it it could go one scenario is what's
happened in the past look they retaliate
and then numbers start to rise meaning
casualties and you know Israel will stop
they they you know they typically will
say look don't Don't Preach to to us
about morals right because you know look
what happened over the weekend as as a
point uh but I think usually what would
happen is the US allies
would have a off the radar very serious
conversation at a certain point when it
starts to look like look this is you
know we got to stop because you're
risking fissures in the support that
exists for Israel and at that point
typically you know that's when the
Israeli government will back off and say
okay we've we've we've done what we need
to do and they'll draw a line and say
we've accomplished a goal and and
frankly you're again you're not I don't
you know maybe I'm wrong but you're not
going to destroy Hamas but they will get
to a certain point that pressure will
build and they'll issue a statement that
basically says we have degraded we have
we have crushed them we have done
whatever however they're going to have
to frame it right and then Hamas will do
what they do and they'll release you
know their PR statements and say yeah
look you know you could couldn't do it
you look at how many civilians you
killed and by the way we're still here
and it'll just keep going like it's been
going since yeah turn of the century I
mean yeah yeah you go back to whatever
World War I M the the you know Pat used
a word that I think is uh very important
the residual effect okay so the last big
dust up here was in' 05 the
disengagement everything there there's
been conflicts in between no doubt um
but it's about to get ugly right now the
residual effect so let's say it takes
you talked about unemployment the a
million of the two million are young
people younger people yeah so let's say
there's a bunch of 10-year-olds right
now um kids they're running the streets
You' have seen the video of like uh the
literal kids beating up an Israeli kid
because he was Israeli like he was
captured all right so you see this so
you talk about the residual effect so
you know what are the sports that they
these boys watch what are the big teams
in Gaza there's no teams there's no
Sports there's no Idols to look up to
I'm not looking up to Michael Jordan
let's say or Ronaldo or Messi or Gretzky
whoever it is who they look up to are
these Freedom Fighters we call them
terrorists but they call them Freedom
Fighters Mars in in their own Community
yeah and and there's generational hate
it just gets it's get it's get passed
along because yeah I mean the trauma
imagine kids again you know and we have
to be more uh I don't want to say
sophisticated because I'm not
sophisticated but you have to be more
complicated in your thinking and we tend
we're not right we tend not to
particularly here in the states where
you got three minutes to cover a news
story and everything's superficial and
but you can you can have real empathy
for a a five or six or seven or eighty
old or a teenager living in Gaza right
and and the the the terrible conditions
and there doesn't seem to be where where
is the future where is it going to lead
how do I make my life better you can
have those thoughts while still being
absolutely disgusted right and at some
core of your being saying no we got to
have some Revenge here for for the
horrible things that Hamas does right
and again putting their own people at
risk because that's how they survive
that's how Hamas
keeps going but um you know typically we
don't do that typically we don't have
really
layered conversations but you can you
know you can have two competing thoughts
in your head at the same time but at the
end of the day this is sort of the
Quagmire that that everything comes down
to is that you know everything comes
down to polarity right like you know the
the you know the Sun and the Moon right
man and woman it's complete opposite you
know I think it was MLK that famously
said you don't fight Darkness or hate
with more hate you do it with love you
do it with Sunshine all all that fun
stuff but even if you do a PR Campaign
Of Love Like Pat pointed out they're
founding principles are your
Annihilation so how do you love someone
and Hey listen I we can get along we can
do this they're just like yeah I still
want to kill you yeah know their point
of view from Hamas point of view
hezbollah's point of view is if you
accommodate Israel yeah if if if like a
citizen of of of or not a citizen but a
resident of Gaza you accommodate Israel
you talk about then you're a traitor to
Islam right right that's just the the
fact of the matter in terms of how they
so yeah you're you're the idea that
you're going to you know hug your enemy
to death there you know in response to
something that they they've just
done it's not going to work you were
shaking your head as as I said that what
was it that you yeah you you know like
um
um you got kids let's just say Okay
somebody God forbid does something to
your kid okay or somebody your son is 14
years old
he's walking you guys going to a
restaurant together with you your wife
your two kids and somebody kills you in
front of uh him at 14 years old God
forbid let me tell
you I mean that's not going to leave
that kid never okay so maybe he finds
Jesus and he learns to forgive okay now
let's take a 100 kids who have
experienced that say 60 of them are like
look God I'm going to forgive the man
and move on you see these videos and
their viral videos where the person who
killed the person's kid comes and hugs
him it's like oh my God okay great but
40 of them they I'm not going to be like
that bro nope okay why do you think
revenge videos do movies do so well
freaking what's the D not Daniel deis
what's the other guy that keeps doing
Revenge movies taking two taking eight
taking 40 what is what's the Liam how
many Takens do we need to do you know
what it tells you it tells you freaking
the world loves Revenge movies because
they want to seek Vengeance why do they
keep making these movies because we
relate the one movie that uh that the
old one Mel Gibson did where the bad guy
walks into the apartment and his son
starts peeing and he looks at his I
don't know if you remember that scene he
looks at his son his son is peeing it
looks at the guy he realizes the Killer
and then he changes the behavior to get
a hold of this guy what is it called
Ransom Ransom is the movie Ransom good
for you or even a gladiator right my
name is
Maximus
rev Man on Fire really memorize that
some of the greatest movies of all time
are Revenge so what is this mean this
ain't never stopping no it is never
Because by the way by the way can I
interrupt and just say we also can't
leave out Charles Bronson and death wish
you can't that's I mean fair enough fair
enough for that our apologies to the
Charles Bronson we apiz on the entire
podcast but but the point is this ain't
never going to stop so the only thing
you can do it's like listen there's
nothing you can do about dying what you
could do is delay when you're going to
die okay so okay if you eat ice cream
every day smoke two packs of cigarettes
a day you drink every day you know
you're you're increasing the chance of
dying earlier if you got blood pressure
you got all this other stuff you're
dealing with okay and if you take care
of your health you exercise you eat good
diet you know you're extending how long
you could live okay and if your job's
not a risky thing but no matter what
this ain't going away no so everything
so so then what becomes a solution
here's the only solution I think about
honestly the only solution I think about
is the following if you really unpack
this what is the only solution there's
only one solution okay
is
Hardcore putting the fear into your
enemy earning
respect and being gentle where you don't
have to raise your
voice if they fear you if they respect
you
and you set the tone of who you are and
you're not an about it then
you're kind of like all right cool we
know you got power we know if you cross
the line with you you can annihilate us
but we like you respectful let's figure
out a way to coexist but we can't mess
with you right this is leading with
strength this isn't anything new that
we're talking about right there's
leaders that led the way and created
peace in a society or in a nation or a
country or city or region by having a
strong military you know I Idaho but why
do people move to Idaho because Idaho
leads I think one the top what do you
call a license to carry Everybody's Got
a Gun whatever the numbers is gu right
crime is low I dare you you go to
restaurant if there's 100 people there
probably 50 of them have a gun with them
stupid don't don't be stupid nobody
nobody's jacking the uh the stinker gas
station somebody's carrier yeah and then
you go to Chicago and guess what you're
in a restaurant with 100 people in there
the 20 people that have guns they just
got out of jail and they got it
illegally and guess what they can ruin
your life so which place would you
rather live so I think the only
way this gets me more thinking about
again where we live you see the Iron
Dome you're like huh what a great thing
by the way you know how much they spent
on the Iron Dome $210 million that's all
it was yeah it's crazy crazy right 210
million 2000 I think it was 2006 2007
the whole thing with the you know hezb
coming from Lebanon they're like okay we
got to build an iron doome us even
helped it and I even searched the Rob
check to see how many iron domes we have
in America it says two but I don't know
if we have iron domes in America I've
got I've got one over my compound in
Idaho yeah I say you see the US military
has two Iron Dome batteries that were
supplied in late 2020 I don't know if we
have iron domes I mean we have Las we're
laser maybe we should use our uh
diplomatic and friendly relationship
with Israel to help us figure out say we
have lasers you said we have lasers 100%
if we have lasers how the hell couldn't
we laser down a freaking balloon for
hours we have lasers Pat we have to let
it go through till stop it we have
lasers we actually do have lasers but
I'm sure we have lasers but if we out
there freaking can I ask you can I ask
you a question Mike so I mentioned you
got the reference right you know what
mov is this these I want sharks with
freaking laser that's awesome okay
good before we shift gears can I just
follow cuz I'm
P You're bring up a good point with like
how you solve this so the unemployment
thing is is it 50% Gaza 50% in Gaza yes
look I I think especially and by the way
some say that's a low number right so
you know what's the unemployment rate in
the United States right now three and a
half% you know all we got to get down on
3% oh my God during Co it went up to 20%
whatever it was we have no idea what
it's like to wake up and literally there
it is 3.8% have no job no career no
skill set you pray you're with your
family respect but you know don't
discount not that you guys are don't
discount the importance of work and
earning and what it does for giving you
a purpose and giving you
meaning and also the the concept of
making yourself better that's that's a
human thing 100% And and it um it's so
essential to having purpose
so you know the what's the GDP of Gaza
what do they produce I don't know but if
I'm them you know talk about selling the
dream selling hope you know you can look
at a little country in the Middle East
like the UAE Dubai everything that goes
on there where were they 50 years ago
piece of piece of sand so when you can
give hope to people and say you don't
have to be 50% unemployment you don't
have to be the uh purveyor of terrorism
you don't have to just be think about
death and destruction and uh retri ution
your whole life there's a better plan
out there because what you're doing is a
is a road to nowhere so they do have a
blueprint and a template with the UAE
small uh Gulf States whether it's Kuwait
whatever and say like when's the last
time you heard about Kuwait attacking
anything you obviously the first uh
Desert Storm but there there's a
blueprint and there's Cas they would
tell you Palestinians would tell you
Gaza would tell you this is the fault of
the Israeli folks this is the fault of
the blockade this is the fault of the
land water air blockade that you guys
have created and the reason why we can't
have any kind of business being done
here if it wasn't for you guys if it
wasn't for Israel this wouldn't happen
so now Israel's mindset some people are
saying hey you got 22 Arab Nations why
don't you go to one of them choose
choose to go to one of the Arab Nations
can you pull up the Arab Nation list Rob
Algeria Bahrain you know uh uh jouti
your favorite Egypt Iraq Jordan Kuwait
Lebanon Libya Morocco Oman pal you know
Qatar go to one of these why don't you
go to one of these Arab Nations if you
feel so so Israel some folks in Israel
wanted to be just go to complete
different but I tell you if I'm a
president right now okay and imagine
that $100 million we spent on uh uh
Ukraine okay let's take that1 billion
bring everybody in that's military folks
and make a list of all the threats okay
one by one by one by one in every
possible way make the investment to
getting everything done the southern
border done uh above it whatever kind of
protection we give done whatever other
things we can do to create an Iron Dome
above the most important places that we
have in uh our country whatever that is
if it's the financial Capital the world
in New York boom do it if it's you know
the Pentagon White House boom if it's
the ports we got to protect in Long
Beach Jacksonville you know Texas you
know even say boom protect the ports
protect the port that we have we have
port in in New York around that area
boom protect it everything becomes dude
play defense
invest stack yourself up with your
defense where you're so protected and
then tell everybody what we just did and
how we're protected and don't compromise
anybody and everybody the fact that both
the left and the right can you imagine
how stupid this is to be more excited
about winning an election as a Democrat
to compromise your border it is more
important for a Democrat to win an
election then to compromise the
protection of your border acting like
you care about your people to the point
where even Democrats in New York are
turned around saying we can't afford to
do this Chicago we can't afford to do
this get them out of our gym people in
Texas we can't afford to do this Arizona
we can't afford to do this California we
can't afford to do this no no it's okay
as long as we do this we can keep
winning elections is it your political
party over your country number one if
somebody ran right now in
2024 you know what would be a big
campaign right now
what like if if the debate that's coming
up right now I'm sure one of them's
going to do hit this message but my
entire campaign would be around
strengthening the military so we don't
have to go to war and nobody can M with
I would strengthen the military The Bard
is all of that stronger especially today
at a time like this Trump hit that
message in 2016 when he ran on that and
guess what happened you know a lot of
people wanted that's exactly what they
wanted they wanted the wall they wanted
protection they wanted to be protected
from some of these things but even more
today than before because
70,000 people from 2021 to 2023 came
here who from Syria who are from
Afghanistan who from Iran from ywhere
what are we talking about Y and by the
way if you give but and you mentioned
this Pat if you give a 100 million that
we were supposed to give to
Ukraine billion you know what's going to
happen zinski is going to be on the
first flight and he's going to be like
you bought iron what that's for me that
we can't take you know what zalinski
would do yeah he'd have a heart attack
he F and complain I'm sorry was that
that was your Ukrainian Ukraine he's
like you give Iron Dome for what that's
for my country Che he would go back to
being a phenomenal comedian that's exact
yeah that's hilarious ask you a question
so I touched on it um with Jason about
uh khed M's uh message calling for
tomorrow to be a terror day Adam you
know did a very very conservative number
1% we actually figured it's probably 20%
so you have the 250 million you know
Muslims that actually really really
would do harm to us cuz they actually
hate us uh Customs and Border Patrol Pat
mentioned 1.5 million illegals have come
in here 70,000 that are what was it pat
special interest illegal aliens so Mike
these let's and not forget the 200 FBI
Terror watch list folk that we caught
Mike how well you also have don't forget
you also have all the goway so you know
we have noide idea how many other
special interest aliens so mik who knows
right what what what do you think Mike
and not to be we're not fear-mongering
we're just being optimistic bro like
don't I don't want to have our pants
down like oh we don't know what the'll
happen how how concerned are you what
are the odds Mike that they're they
obviously a a shitload of them here uh
you have people like the the M michall
Khaled guys saying guys we need to
attack How concerned should we be as
America for some something like that
going down here well you should always
be concern concerned U if you don't have
a a uh a secure border right I mean
that's just you should always be aware
of the fact that if if we're not
controlling and securing the border
which doesn't make you a racist or
anti-immigrant it every other Nation
does it we just happen to be the ones
that apologize for it for some reason or
don't actually do it then yeah you the
problem is then you don't know where you
are on the alert scale right because so
this this call for resistance and
however else they want to phrase it um
it's a problem because as as as Pat said
we've had over the past two years we've
had a ridiculous number of of encounters
with individuals from Lebanon from Yemen
from Syria from Afghanistan from
Pakistan coming over and yeah fine some
of them are looking for a better life of
that that that goes without saying but
we we don't know and the Biden
Administration can't tell you there's
some estimates that maybe there's 1 and
a half million God ways during the Biden
Administration right but that's a
complete guess in a sense they're
extrapolating on the data that they
they've collected over the the years so
they're just they're making some
assumptions but um yeah so I think and
and look there every time there's a
escalation in over in the Middle East
you know local state federal and Intel
Community everybody gathers together and
says okay now now what's going to happen
you know what if and and where's that
attack going to come from and what's the
problem and so there's that game goes on
all the time there's there're always
tablet topping exercises but um you know
the problem is that we don't have a
there's there there's nothing secure
about this border at this point I hate
again I hate to what do you think is
Mike is is it just is it I mean we're
not stupid it's not because they they're
humanitarians Mike and they give a damn
my orchest is just sitting there smiling
in Congress he doesn't give a is it
on purpose like are they trying to
destroy us from within cuz they can't
deny the number that we just talked
about Mikey they're here these people
are here I don't think it's I I mean
again I don't think they're trying to
destroy us from within or anything like
that I'm not necessarily you know I
don't usually go to that route but but
um I think that there is sort of a
self-righteous sense among a a sector of
the Dem party that says you know well we
if we do talk about secure borders it is
racist and we're better than that and
they're just not they're not smart
enough to understand look you can fix
actually and have a fair immigration
policy and you could also have a secure
border one doesn't discount the other
but you cannot fix the immigration
system until you have a secure border
right it's not going to work this time
though Mike cuz I'll tell you I fell for
it the first time I'm guilty mean to
Trump the Mago build a wall make Mexico
pay for it the the the the media oh he's
racist that's what's going on it's like
we've seen the results right of actually
not implementing a more secure border
we've seen the results of not having the
wall we've seen the results of just wide
open borders and now Biden building some
exact they late what we were told and
you know this is the whole problem is
like people make mistakes but you don't
double down on your mistake you say hey
look I probably should have uh you know
looked into this more like whatever this
is eight years ago whatever the number
was but the point is the Wall's racist
the Wall's medieval this is a medieval
do work this is a medieval solution to a
modern day problem though oh my God he
thinks all Mexicans are rapists and drug
like how many times do they play that
yeah but here's the reality uh at the
very least a wall will help secure the
Border or do we want to start helping to
secure the Border or do nothing yeah and
I think most Americans if you just sort
of frame it that way they're like yeah
you know I don't you know not a fan of
trump let's say but yeah I'm cool the
wall I had this conversation with
somebody who will remain nameless just a
day and a half ago where we were having
this conversation about the wall along
the southern border and they said well
look it didn't do any good in Israel you
know you know most Hightech you know and
all you can do is sit and stare at
somebody like that and you think I'm I'm
sorry but do you imagine that you know
that's what we're talking about
here that level of of breach yeah I'm
sorry uh you know as we're talking about
these hordes of uh Latin American people
coming in yeah migrant workers for the
most part to work for the most part
whereas you have Hamas literally killing
people so the equivocation there is
insane yeah well I mean and Mike I've
seen a lot of videos thank God to Elam
mus that we could see it that there's
Americans recording people from China
people from the Middle East nobody
speaks English they're like what are you
where are you going where are you from
they they can't even they have they zero
English and they're coming in here and
they're young AG men with no kids it's
like what are you they like have a fake
Mexican mustache on and just cuz they're
brown from uh Afghanistan they speak no
this oh yeah go just a Boll footage of
people crossing the border illegally
into the United States so what what do
you think about so V rawani said
something he said if I was a president
one of the first things I would do one
of the f is that a do but you remember
is that a dog and and this doesn't help
real quick V this doesn't help that you
know Governor Abbott in Texas he tried
to put up these like floats yeah you
know what that was these floaties and
then you know supre Court the federal
government said no you can't even have
that on the real Grand River the states
tried to do something about this they're
like yeah sorry buddy that don't play
this whole deal yeah no they tried to
say look this is a you know this is your
the the free and fair passage on
waterways act you know you're you're
breaching that with putting out these
barriers and uh I again I you it it's
it's true that we have a flawed
immigration system right and it's true
that the country was built on
immigration oh fine you know none of
that's in question but can have a a
controlled and secure border like all
the other nations I've been to have and
I don't see anybody I mean try moving
into Mexico illegally and getting a work
permit and benefits Mike what do you
think about V rasani said one of the
first things that he would bu I'm sorry
I'm still laughing because we saw the
dog go over the dog like like the dog
made it but anyway uh the said one of
the first things he would do Mike was
put cuz we have a bunch of people bunch
of reservist bunch of soldiers that are
just here we're not like actively in a
crazy War he would set up you know
military at the border like if we're
going to get serious wall okay I get it
build it but put up the military to
guard it protect it and just like
enough's enough I know Adam we deal with
people coming in tunnels and but if
we want to get serious guess what let's
get the military involved and let's not
like you'll know not to just show up and
like what Caravans of 3,000 5,000 6,000
people it's like we H like enough is
enough well I think part of it is I I
think it's it there's there's more
layers to that I'm not I don't
necessarily agree with Vi about you know
let's let's post the military down on
the on the border yeah if we if if
suddenly you know the alert you know
goes up and we've got a a problem uh but
in the case that we've got part of the
problem is um Administration policy
right and people aren't stupid overseas
they understand when you know it's a
it's a uh an open situation or they're
basically being invited to come in right
despite the fact that then they they
said no no we told people don't show up
well no all their rhetoric during the
campaign all their talk you know and all
their criticism of of Trump's policies I
all of that helped contribute to the
fact that you had this this migration
this large inflow and you can do that
along with then creating a more secure
border through physical barriers through
surveillance through detection through
ground you know there's there's things
you can be doing without saying we're
going to we're going to send the
military down there and post up uh you
can beef up CB BP right and and this
would drive the the the squad and
Capitol Hill crazy but you could you
know beef up ice and CBP what CBP uh
Customs and Border Protection okay um so
we have elements in place that can
handle this problem if you if you allow
them to do their job right and if you
create you know the necessary
infrastructure you got to empower them
EMP you're not doing it that's the word
right they're not feeling empowered
they're feeling like they're uh uh
crippled like they can't do their job by
way I want to read two stories that may
be one of the stories you're hearing a
lot of Republicans coming out talking
about the the $6 billion freeze all this
stuff but I want to read the story how
the AL AA mosque became a flasho in the
Israeli Palestine conflict this is an
NPR story okay that came out a couple
years ago recent attacks by Hamas
against Israel resulting in casualties
on both sides were partly triggered by
Israeli raids around the alaka mosque in
Jerusalem this area has become a flasho
due to a long-standing Palestinian
grievance is Decades of military
occupation and a decade and a half of
Siege in Gaza Strip which has left
millions of Palestinians living in the
difficult conditions according to ysf
monoar a senior fellow at the Arab
Center Washington DC in recent years and
months the escalation of violence
against Palestinians has been noted by
the United Nations and governments
throughout the region who've been
warning that his escal this escalation
of Israeli violence against Palestinians
going to lead to an explosion in this
region so I don't know if you know the
story I don't know if you're aware of
the story what are your thoughts about
this yeah um
it the the the history of of of
Palestine the history of the area right
you
you I again there's there's a certain um
cynicism uh in the consistency and and
there it's depressing when you think
about the consistency of all this I mean
you can go all the way back to you know
look the Israelites right I mean again
not to get deep in history but
Israelites controlled Palestine you know
back go to the wherever the Iron Age the
Romans Romans took over and um there was
a Jewish Revolt you know I'm jumping
period to period but I guess the point
that when you started reading that I I
thought of you know the Romans putting
down the Jewish revolt and one of the
things they did was they destroyed the
the Jewish temple right which was
incredibly important right to to the
Jewish population there at the time um
this is it's always been a flasho so
whether you're talking about the mosc
you're talking there are
certain not the over symol there's
certain very few uh points that surface
all the time in in this conflict right
and so I
think part of it is I think people put
their they they just shrug and say it's
never going to solve itself so I was
thinking about what I mean what you were
saying about what's the end game what or
what how you know how do you deal with
it and I I think that's the question
that has to be asked because we always
get we get locked into these moments we
get locked into the Palestinians and
their their concern over the the the
mosque we get locked in over the the
issue of Jerusalem and and is it open um
there are these the I don't know what
what has to happen to broaden our
approach to say at some point we have to
solve this because everybody sitting
here agrees two million people in a
space that's maybe a fourth the size of
London you know is is not right right so
we have at some point there's got to be
a SE change that
says um somehow you've got to create
something different if we keep doing
this because I guarantee you they're
going to finish this operation they're
going to they're going to get vilified
the Israelis I mean um and we're going
to go right back to the status quo oh
thanks very much yeah I've got some here
if you would have drank the Vault yeah
that's what we got a bunch of them you
we have ACH Rob do me a favor just pull
up the map of the Middle thinking should
have had the Vault there pull up a map
of the Middle East but you know by the
way the the story The any mosque that
gets blown up I'm not happy about this
any church that gets blown up any like
there's certain things that I believe
are up so so this is you're kind of
almost in Southeast Asia so just go
punch in on the the Middle East so okay
so go back out so this go punch out just
a little bit so this is what we would
call the Middle East yeah to your left
you have Egypt uh leanon Syria okay so
this this is what this is the Arab world
let's say now if you go all the way in
tiny tiny tiny you'll find little old
little old Israel okay I feel like I
famili back in middle school there you
go think it's
important so there's there's Israel
right there to the to the southern left
is the Sinai Peninsula which they gave
back to Egypt after the war okay the
Golan Heights which has been a area of
of discrepancy so why am I doing all
this you have Israel right there now
punch all the way back out so we're
talking about a little tiny fraction of
the Middle East where
it's you pales in comparison to the Arab
world all right what's my point so you
have 15 million Jews living in this
little tiny tiny tiny little area you
have two million gazin uh Palestinians
living in this little area you know this
entire Middle Eastern world that
empathizes and sympathizes for the most
part with Gaza first
question what are you going to do with
these 15 million Jews if you do want to
expel them go there go there you're
going to expel these Jews where are they
going okay they fled to Israel why
because they were persecuted in Europe
Germany Poland aitz go there Russia
everything that happened there whether
they were in Morocco whether they were
in Libya because there's called sapharic
Jews that are from the Middle East and
there's called ashkanazi Jews that
essentially were from Europe but how did
they end in Europe is because they were
expelled from you called it the Homeland
and you know Jews have been fighting
Wars since the kingdom of Judea and
Europe people the Assyrians and the
Babylonians and the Phoenicians and
everything but this has always been sort
of the Jewish homeland and it's like you
said the Romans and all this so my
question is this what's easier to do if
if we were just going to make a deal and
had zero Motion in it you're going to
remove these 15 million people somehow
and where are they going there's only
one Jewish Homeland one Jewish state in
the world where they going or you have 2
million people in Gaza living under dire
conditions and you have an entire Arab
world that what won't take them in right
right Egypt I was I was going to say the
Arab world has you always have to ask
that question what have they done to
actually benefit or help the Palestinian
cause so you can hate on Israel you can
call them an apartheid state you could
you do all that but okay how are you
helping Gaza so will you send them money
to create more war how do you how do you
Empower these people how do you help
these people how do you have
humanitarian Aid and take these people
in so it's not just one constant War
cycle of War yeah that's all I'm saying
here is that there's so much Arab land
respect there's this tiny little thing
called Israel yet they're the problem it
doesn't add up well they try I mean you
can go back what 30s 40s um when they
were proposing a two-state solution and
every Arab nation that that was there at
the time voted against it said no not
going to happen you know and the uh and
the uh the Jewish population was
basically behind it saying yeah let's do
the two-state you know solution but you
know so we've been fighting this um we
seeing the same things over and over
again for a long time so you're right I
mean those are the but I think those are
the sort of questions that have to be
asked rather than you know necessarily
okay well how long's this operation
going to you know last this this time
around right because there'll be another
one what are the other options other
than let's kill each other right it's
like it's like the pandemic we're going
to get another pandemic right so maybe
it would have been smart to demand
transparency from China so that we know
how to prevent or at least mitigate the
next pandemic but no we don't do it you
know we we we we always get stuck in in
the small details and and and not that
again not that this conflict is a small
detail but you know what I mean and in
terms of we got to solve a bigger
problem here and I think what happens
often times people say well it's always
been like this so geez you know we're
never going to come up with a solution
and yeah probably won't I to be cical I
I think the only solution is a strong
defense and strong offense if you got
that in place where the other person
knows not to mess with you great you
know we had a kid uh in school like you
know in school the first time somebody
tries to bully you and you hit back and
then everybody in school sees it and
like you know what I'm probably not
going to fight Vinnie moving forward
just simple as that I'm good I'm not
going to fight the guy anymore there
needs to be a little bit that but let me
let me let me read this story about
Trump trump slams Netanyahu as not
prepared for Hamas attack okay Trump
strongly criticized Netanyahu asserting
that Israel was not prepared for the
Hamas attack uh he stated he was not
prepared and Israel was not prepared and
under Trump they wouldn't have had to
they wouldn't have had to be prepared he
also questioned who would have thought
their intelligence would have been able
to pick this up he continued uh he
revealed this disappointment atyo during
his presidency citing a pivotal moment
when is Israel backed out of a plan to
kill General
Solani head of Iran's uh K's force and
Trump disclosed we had everything all
set to go and the night before it
happened I got a call that Israel will
not be participating in the attack he
emphasized I'll never forget that BB net
Netanyahu let us down
so I you know the most unpredictable
things comes out you know when he said
how do you process this statement here
yeah well how do you process the fact
that you know we're going to end up with
Biden and Trump again as our
presidential candidates that's that's
pay-per-view payview pay-per-view wow
that's actually really smart you can
figure out a way to revenue this 99
bucks look um I'm at a point where I
actually praise Trump on what he's right
on but I'll call Trump out on what I
think he's wrong on there there's
certain people that on one side or the
other and that's how you operate with
Trump right but there's something called
multilateralism and there's something
called unilateralism I mean the
definition of unilateralism is I alone
can fix it you're going to fix the world
I'll end Russia War one day I hope you
do buddy um but an ally like BB who
believe me was no friend to Obama
administration and bid was no friend to
BB but this is where you you know the
the whole personal attacks and if you're
not loyal to him this is where it kind
of falls on deaf ears where it's like
bro like this ain't about you and
Netanyahu or like you alone can fix it
the one thing we need in this world in
this crazy world with North Korea Iran
Russia China all our alliances
now you want to push away Israel not
that they would from America is not the
sitting president although Rosanne
thinks he's still the commander
commander um you know you Europe you
want to you want to drive them away
drive a wedge with them it's to me it's
the the personal the name calling the
vindictiveness is sort of it that's
that's the part of trump that I that
some people are just like Ah that's why
he lost last time that's why he lost it
last time all the people were tired of
the chaos and they were tired of the the
noise um like despite whether they might
have liked the policy
yeah a policy but most people don't vote
for policies quite frankly they're not
hard enough to vote for policy
complicated in this situation you know
what just silence you don't you don't
have to say anything you don't need to
say anything in this situation they're
dealing with what they're dealing with
the last thing I want is somebody going
hey if it was me like nobody nobody
wants to hear that Trump is an
opportunist and he's a brilliant
marketer and he's going to take this
moment to say you know by like Trump by
the way P Trump was here with this whole
conversation that you guys are talking
about the Gaza and the Palestinians you
know he would say why do we just take
them bring them to Canada give them a
big piece of Canada CU you think about
it Canada's not doing he's like
bring him to Canada give him a chunk of
Canon Egypt why
not do he would listen hey guys BL
word get it up by the way you know you
know you know I just like Trump trump at
21 years old okay if he was in the Army
you would say hey man you know in high
school uh Adam scored 62 points in a
game he would say 62 points if I played
against him I would have scored 101
points that's it he's Uncle Rico from
Napoleon Dynamite like how much want to
make a bet I'll throw the
ball that's Donald Trump Ric he's the
guy from Durk digler boogy nights where
so what do you bench 180 what do you
bench I bench 185 really what do you
squat I squat about 225 how about you
230 oh my God always going one up here
that is so I mean and I I get it he's
trying to say relevant and he feels like
he was cheated but by the way but but
but let let me let me give my my uh uh
part that I relate to him okay the book
of the month we have this month is Four
Agreements okay I love that book you
know what the four things are Dave MZ
yeah what's the book about though it's
about so it's it's about keep your word
uh keeping your keeping your word don't
like holding grudges to people it's four
very simple things I I have it on my I
have it on my yeah it's it's phenomenal
oh sorry Don Miguel Ruiz yeah David so
what are The Four Agreements one of them
is keep your word the other one is if
you can uh never self talk negative
about yourself or no or other people
always speak don't take anything
personal be impeccable with your word
don't make assumptions always do your
best right okay easy easy you know for
the last 14 years if I've worked with
anybody and I w i i go and look the last
20 some years okay and I look at where
conflicts has been in my for me
personally with relationships I've had
with direct reports of people that get
paid very well to do their job you know
what's the number one thing not 90% of
the conflicts a person didn't keep their
word okay so now somebody could
say you're such a stickler man Let It Go
people are not perfect totally get it
that's the wiring okay that's the wiring
I am this guy I've been like this for 44
years I'm my father son my father God
forbid if you told him a month ago the
next time you come you're going to bring
him a bottle of topeo oh your dad if you
show up without topeo do you know what
he's going to do to you all night at
dinner why didn't you bring it he can
never keep his word no Vinnie never he
told I asked him for one thing I asked
him for one thing one thing all this
stuff I do for him for one thing he
doesn't bring me to aacho you know who
Trump is Netanyahu didn't bring him to
Pacho that's it you got to bring it he
said let's go do by the way had another
guy the day before we started a company
it was a guy that said hey Pat you and I
are going together we're going to run
this company to get insurance company
you know what he does the night before
we're about to start it he backs
out for for at my wedding he's telling
everybody we're starting a company at my
wedding he was one of my groomsmen all a
sudden no I'm backing out because you
know I'm going to make sure you don't
get sued he was afraid wow he was
worried of course we're going to get
sued yeah you're becoming a direct
competitor and you got to see what we
can do from there let's roll right and
then boom we had to do what we did but
the the more the stories I understand
what he's
saying I get the fact that if behind
closed doors you said you're going to be
part of thisam so I'm not the only guy
that takes it but this the part where
you got to respect this guy can you
bring up the one scene Rob with uh Trump
sitting there with Schumer and Pelosi
these These are the kind of things that
I value love this is what I respect I
mean you can say whatever you want I
respect brass balls when he says you
don't want to take the blame I'll take
the blame I'll shut the down I'll take
the blame can you find this clip Rob
it's one of the best Clips out there for
leadership because he brought the media
and in front of media he says I so don't
give a about you writing negative
things about me that I'm going to tell
these two people that are chickens
they're worried that they're going to
write about them I'm going to say I shut
it down and then the rest of the world's
like holy this guy actually pulled
it off and he did have the whole press
in there so so that's the part where I I
understand like for me I'm sitting said
okay this the one if you can make how
big is this thing by the way how many
minutes is it now go okay so go on the
minutes where you see if you go on the
graph no no no go on the graph on the
time right there you see where the
tension side right there click right
there where the mountain is yeah click
right there and press play here we go
volume so let's see if we can find it on
Twitter it is such a powerful clip press
play good as that if not better so we
have done a lot of work on the wall a
lot of wall is built a lot of people
don't know that a lot of wall is
renovated we have walls that were in
very bad condition that are now in A1
tiptop shape uh and uh frankly uh some
wall has been reinforced by our military
our military has done a fantastic job so
the wall will get built but we may not
uh we may not have an agreement today we
probably won't but we have an agreement
on other things that are really good
Nancy would you like to say
something well thank you Mr President
for the opportunity to meet with you uh
so that we can work together in a
bipartisan way uh to meet the needs of
the American people I think the American
people recognize that we must keep
government open that a shutdown is not
worth anything and that we should not
drunk about 20 seconds away watch it's
coming she's drunk pat down you have a
White House you have the Senate you have
the House of Representatives you have
the votes you should pass it no we don't
have the votes because in the Senate we
need 60 votes no but in the half we
don't have could bring it up right now
yeah but I can't excuse me but I can't
get it passed in the house if it's not
going to pass in the Senate I don't want
to waste time well well the fact is you
can get it started that way the house we
can get passed very e enough and we do
but the problem is the Senate because we
need 10 Democrats to vote and they vot
Point Mr look at Mike Pence the point is
is that there are equities to be weighed
and we're here to have a conversation in
a prayerful way so I don't think we
should have a debate in front of the
Pres he doesn't care but the fact is
Chuck the entire media
which Administration would do this do it
immediately would get it passed very
easily in the house we would get it
Nancy I'd have it passed in two seconds
it doesn't matter though because we
can't get it passed in the Senate
because we need 10 Democrat votes that's
the again let us have our conversation
and then we meet with the Press again
but the fact let us have the
conversation leg then we meet with the
Press we do you begin fast forward about
20 seconds if you can do that
says the ownership will be fast forward
cuz I found the clip where he says it
cuz it's when him and Schumer are going
at it Schumer is looking so I love he's
about to have a heart attack well I
found a shorter clip on really looks
like Mr Burns I just aie but it's
important Juck did you want to say Sir
here's what I want to say we have a lot
of disagreements here the Washington
Post today gave you a whole lot of
pinocchios because they say you
constantly misstate how much the wall is
built how much of the wall is built and
how much is there but that's not the
point here we have a disagree about the
wall whether it's effective or not on
border security but on the wall we do
not want to shut down the government you
have called 20 times to shut down the
government you say I want to shut down
the government we don't we want to come
to an agreement if we can't come to an
agreement we have solutions that will
pass the House and Senate right now and
will not shut down the government and
that's what we're urging you to do not
threaten to shut down the government you
let me just finish you can't get time
you shut it down yeah let me say
something Mr President you just say my
way or will shut down the government we
have a proposal that Democrats and
Republicans will support to do a CR that
will not shut down the government we
urge you to take it and if it's not good
border security I won very and if it's
not good border security I won't take it
because when you look at these numbers
of the effectiveness of our border
security and when you look at the job
that we're doing with you said is
effective can I be can I tell you
something you just said wall these are
only areas where you have the walls
where you have walls Chuck it's
effective where you don't have walls it
is not effective cameras on your face I
love it we've come in here Mike Pence is
sleeping with his eyes open by the way
go a little bit more forward
article don't have border security we're
not going to keep it with you we are
going to have border secur it's the same
border you're bragging we can build
again is that right good we do see we
get along thank you everybody
you know what he did at the end that we
missed he says I'll take the
responsibility we'll go ahead and shut
it down forget about it I'll go ahead
and do it so for me a part of me is when
when I see him being so maniacal and
detailed about remembering dude you you
you know what kind of enemy you don't
want to face the guy that remembers
every freaking thing you did you know
how an knowing of an enemy it is but you
know what's the good thing about an
enemy like that when he's on your
side I a guy like that is on your side
representing you complicated personality
they tend
to they tend to be unpredictable and the
enemy doesn't like that but what about
so he's coming up it by all accounts it
looks like he's going to be the nominee
right so in your opinion the people that
didn't vote for him the last time which
is why he didn't get reelected are they
going to come back in or how how's the
math work this time around okay you want
to go through that let's go through that
okay how many people voted for Biden 81
million I've been told okay so let me
ask you this let me ask of course C you
for sure know the exact you guys counted
watch this I got it right here in my so
here's a question for you out of the 81
real people of course there are real out
of the 81 million people that voted for
Biden how many of them are still going
to vote and how many of them are having
buyers remorse well see that's and
that's that's the reason I asked that
question is because I think if there was
if there was a the the dynamic here or
the the wild card is that it's Trump
again right I think there's no way the
Dems win if it's not Trump running right
because I think people are going to have
buyers remorse with Biden and we and the
tendency is always you get this this
flip flopping going on so but the
problem is with Trump and again look I
policies I like the policies right I had
no problem with the policies actually
question for you though just let's play
straight up it is Trump Biden okay it is
Trump Biden how many of the 81 million
people that voted for Biden have buyers
remorse and are not going to vote for
him again yeah not saying they're going
to vote for Trump but they may go
independent libertarian or sit this one
out I'm not saying they're going to vote
Trump I think the likelihood there is
they they sit it out yeah it's a but
yeah I I have no idea what do you think
give or take just I mean listen no one's
you're not going to be held accountable
to this and your CI friends are going
say Trump you know it's Trump and so I'd
say because of his polarizing abilities
I I think the number is going to be low
I what do you think it is you
know 7% 7% is Trump's winning I go 7% if
that's the case it's over I mean just so
you know that so but let let's go lower
number let's say 4 million that's 5%
okay it's 4.8% if you do four okay okay
so we go 7778 million okay fine um of
the people and by the way I think
there's going to be the 7% is going to
be the right number I think it's going
to be around 75 million to 77 million
votes this time around I think a lot of
people are going to sit this one out
they're not going to vote for Trump but
they're going to sit this one out and
they're not going to vote for RFK some
of the Liberals that are pro vaccine
they're not going to do RFK but I think
RFK is going to take some from Biden and
it's going to take some from Trump okay
now of the people who are the middle
ones the people that matter the most
independent ones the rep the the the
Libertarians Independents how many of
them who voted against Trump in
2020 and now they're seeing every report
came out if that New York Post Story the
Twitter would have been left they know
Trump would have won and if Co doesn't
happen Trump would have won yeah and now
Trump said by the way Trump's ad video
is going to be very easy they said no to
the all is a rapist now Biden's doing
the wall they said no to this he's doing
the they said no to Afghanistan follow
they said no to this God do you know
that Greatest Hits list these marketers
are they're just waiting for this one
now go to the Trump a lot of ammunition
so here's the other part to the here
this the other technical question we
have to answer how many of the people
that are anti-trump okay that are
Lincoln project people now they're
realizing the Lincoln project outside of
one person who was on here last week
your best friend St my boy what's up
Steve outside of him okay Lincoln
project John Weaver came out what did
John Weaver came up with pedophilia
another was a spy for Russia another one
was all this agent all this stuff
Lincoln project is gone they are not
what they were before not this much have
zero credibility today so the Rhino
story those guys that were stealing
votes away they're not there now let's
go the they'll be there'll be another
grift though there will be there's no
question about it yeah but but they
don't have the same credibility and
they're going to say the next in the
Lincoln project that's all what they're
going to say then then it becomes the
people that are pro the santis or the
people that are pro Nikki Haley or
they're Pro Mike Pence his relative
seven people or the people that are pro
you know uh Vic or the people that are
pro whoever those guys are on the stage
right how many of them at first they're
going to say there's no way I'll ever
vote for Trump but at the end they're
going to say I'm going to vote for
Republican okay when you put all of that
stuff together um if there is no
gamification if there is no gamification
if there is gamification if there is hey
World War III is here and we're under
attack and we have to make sure we pause
election and something like that's not
going to be happen if there's no
gamification I think this guy's got a
very clear argument on how to get back
in and I think he's convinced I think
his people are convinced I think some of
the even uh the people who the the
judicial system or doj's not been fair
to them they're not relating to him
saying look at this I relate to this guy
everything they're doing to me I kind of
felt like I went through it except this
guy's a white guy yeah why are they
doing it to him I think there's a lot of
things there that the case could be made
on why he could potentially wion well I
I mean yeah I'd like to I'd love to see
the Republicans win I'd love to see them
take it I just the the worry that I have
is that the polarizing nature of of uh
of him as a candidate and how that could
because again I I think I think the Dems
have made the same calculation their
best chance of winning is to to face
Trump and I you know I I don't they they
they tend to have a better machine right
Republicans never never underestimate
their ability to shoot themselves in the
foot and do something stupid um but yeah
we'll we'll see I I I do want to see a
uh a change in the white house though
because I I can't imagine anybody saying
to themselves you know I'm going to vote
for Biden because I'm okay with KLA
Harris as president of the United States
cuz M I was just on I was just in like
five group chats with cousins and people
and it's it's always the same you know I
I ignore them all freaking day because
it's Trump Biden Biden how can you how I
I'm boggled I asked him how could you
still in your right mind vote are they
that dedicated to the party that you you
still have to vote for Biden nothing is
going on I go what what are you voting
for is it just it's not Trump like are
you that stupid and you don't get like
the house is burning down but you know
what I'm not that's it's the only reason
Biden won because he wasn't Trump yeah
Vinnie I love you brother it still
shocks me that you can't believe that
all half the country hates Trump no not
hat Trump just letting you know they're
never going to vote no I didn't say
hates Trump I'm saying right no I'm
saying this election I'm saying right
now if you can go there and go to the
voting booth and circle in Biden with
all the that's happening you're 75
million people will do about 44% to
47% yes are where he's at letting it
like it's really there there but there
is their the the buyers remorse vote I'm
telling you there are a lot of those
buyers remorse vote can I give you some
like opinion on the numbers by the way
just the same same how do you vote for
Biden that's the same PE you have
friends like this how do you vote for
Trump exact same camp and the numbers
are very clear so whether Biden had 81
million votes or 77 whatever the hell
number he had whatever it's almost
irrelevant to me because the general uh
elector the Electoral College is
determined as the presidents not the uh
total vote the popular vote not the
popular vote so at the end of the day
we've seen this okay it's four or five
states in a handful of cities right that
have that are metaphysically bipolar why
because they voted for Bush then they
voted for Obama then they voted for
Trump then they gave Biden a shot they
are more than willing to give somebody a
shot so these are the same guys that are
like yeah Shuffle up and do we'll go
with Trump again I like they they they
have no allegiance to anybody but
themselves and that's fine but the the
to your point I agree if you put a vivec
on stage with Biden blowout oh for and
Nikki Haley you saw the stat she's five
points up uh even to santis I think he
would give Trump uh give Biden to run
for his money but you're right they're
both hovering in the low 40 approval
rate and I I don't see how they again
and and people always say well the the
Dems are out to get him they're going to
they're going to convict him on
something and I'm thinking well the DNC
doesn't want to convict him because the
DNC wants to run against him right
because the others going roll out
Weekend at Bernie's Biden out there he's
the only guy that's similar in age to
him so he's like well he's not that old
he's only a couple years older than
Trump yeah I don't know I you know
what's going to happen on on the first
Tuesday of November or actually no it's
probably going to take 6 weeks after the
first Tuesday in November of 2024 cuz
you know nowadays elections it takes a
long time to count back in the days we
were such better counters if you think
about it we used to be able to count to
10 like in 3 seconds technology better
technology is like working backwards
right with all the stuff that we got but
eventually within six weeks they're
going to count okay and there's going to
be a group that's going to be like here
we go again you know same guys back up
establish and running the show then
there's going to be another group crying
thinking it's the end of the world but
one of those to is going to happen but
before that happens the next 12 months
oh my God I have a feeling buckle up is
going to be show craziness yeah
show craziness going take place
anyways gang uh hope you enjoyed today's
P podcast Mike Baker's podcast gang Mike
Baker's got a podcast called the
president's Daily Brief a daily podcast
that's available on Spotify iTunes and
the first TV we got the link below in
the description in chat box all over the
place make sure you go subscribe and
listen to The One and Only Mike Baker
take care everybody have a great weekend
bye- bye bye-bye
bye-bye